[Music]
two more coming right up Bucky's got all
the
luck yeah she's pretty no not that lucky
just shipping out tomorrow he's going to
be Aon away for the the rest of us will
still be playing practice missions over
Nebraska don't worry we'll be over there
dropping bombs soon enough fck
next round's on us he's never done that
before so you're Bucky and he's Buck uh
that's a long story they make a nice
pair don't they I should have introduced
them earlier she's leaving tomorrow
everyone needs someone to write to back
home I don't know if John Egan's the
pimp pal
type well maybe if you met a girl worth
writing to you would be a girl with
riding to is hard to find not if you
know where to look
H I see what you mean so you're right me
I already
have you wrote me a
letter what's it say well you have to
wait and find out well when will that be
I sh out i''s say 2 or 3
weeks I miss you
understand right right gentleman a toast
Buck mods hey you love birds we're
toasting Bucky over
here our new AR exac it all the
drunks in the hundreds oh someone's got
to make a nest for the rest of you Doos
cheers major to the hundred best of luck
sir good luck sir thanks save some us
we're going to slooter you guys coming
yeah I got to fly early I don't
think so boys see you tomorrow then bye
M Bucky see you in England remember one
extra blankets and caught with a view
consider it
done he won't tell me what's with the
nicknames SP Mar go ahead go it's a long
story well they met in basic training
before the war
started John uh John was always Bucky
since he was a kid right that's right
yeah and Gail well Gail's always been
gay until first their basic training
this fell walks up to me and says that I
remind him of a guy back home in uh
Wisconsin goes by the name of buck I
tell him my name's Gail Gail clevin and
uh Bucky here he's not deterred no sir
it's uh it's just buck this buck that
buck can you help me tie my shoes Buck
help me fly this plane before I know the
whole damn M their force is calling me
Buck what kind of a name is Gail anyway
you know what you you know what you
should actually be thanking me I did you
a favor for giving me the same name it's
not exactly the same name and it's not
my fault you look exactly like Buck from
man what kind of man does that to his
best friend a so sweet we need music
okay don't go away
girl you're going to dance with me
before this night is still oh don't make
me dance
March pick a good one Shaw Benny Goodman
hey you know else I am amazed that my
friends you don't like to dance with a
beautiful woman you don't drink you
don't gamble you looking like sports
well we are one of life's great
Mysteries oh I love that yes
yeah
[Music]
so this is
it this is
it see you in a few weeks if I don't die
first hate to break it to you Bucky but
you are the hundreds air executive now
you're not going over there to fly
missions look I uh I had a conversation
with the co over at the 389th and I'm
flying with those boys until you guys
show up I'll be an observation pilot
you son of a yeah well someone's
got to taste a little combat tell you
what it's really like up there well
thought you'd die on me before I get
over
there don't count on
[Music]
it get the not down let's get this fire
out come on Faster come to help
us
that